Wes Craven literally like almost every
time I was about to throw in the towel
and quit I always got a call from Wes
and it would be like I'm thinking of
doing Nightmare on Elm Street part three
and they've asked me to write the script
would you be interested yeah Dream
Warriors I have an idea for you to be in
it and I was like thank you Wes thank
you so much and same thing happened with
Wes Craven's New Nightmare I was I just
had a baby and I couldn't get an
audition to save my life I remember
going out for it was like technician
number three
for you know a TV series about you know
things that didn't even have names like
I finally told my agent if the part
doesn't have a name I don't want to even
go